can we um
instill consciousness into other beings
because that's a sad thought
that whatever
this thing inside our minds that hopes
and dreams and fears and loves
can all die
yeah but i think you already know the
answer to that question
um i have a robot lawnmower at home
my kids call it cc call cutter it's a
robomow
and it the way it works it has an
electric field around the perimeter and
it just tell it the area and it
it goes out and goes from its base
station just mows a bit
gets to the perimeter detects and then
chooses a random angle rotates around
and goes on yeah
but my kids call it call cutter it's a
she i don't know why it's a she they
just they when they were like quite
young they called it
um
i don't want to be sexist there it could
be but they liked um
they gendered the lawnmower they
gendered the lawnmower okay yeah why not
but i was thinking this lawn mower
if you apply integrated information
theory to lawnmower the lawnmower is
conscious
now information integrated information
theory
um is that people say as a flawed way of
measuring consciousness but i don't
think it is i think assembly theory
actually measures consciousness in the
same way consciousness is something that
has generated over a population of
objects of humans consciousness didn't
suddenly spring in our consciousnesses
evolved together right the the fact
we're here and the robots we leave
behind
they all have some of that so we won't
lose it all
sure consciousness requires we have many
models being generated there's not just
one domain specific ai right i think the
the way it create consciousness i'm
going to say unashamedly the best way
chemical to make a consciousness is in a
chemical system because you just have
access to many more states
and the problem right now we're making
silicon consciousness
is you just don't have enough
states so there are more possible states
or sorry there are more possible
configurations possible in your brain
than there are atoms in the universe and
you can you can switch between them you
can't do that on a core i10 it's got
it's got 10 billion 12 billion 14
billion transistors but you can't you
can't reconfigure them as dynamically
well you've shared this intuition
a few times already that
the larger number of states
somehow correlates to greater
possibility of life but
it's also possible the constraints are
essential here yeah yeah i mean but but
coming back to the you worry that
something's lost i agree um but i think
that um
you know we will get to an agi
but i wonder if it's if it's not
it can't be separate from human
it can't be separate from human
consciousness because the causal chain
that produced that came from humans so
the p is what i kind of try and suggest
heavily to people worry about
um the existential threat of ai saying
i mean you put it much more elegantly
earlier like we should worry about
algorithms on dumb algorithms written by
human beings on twitter driving us
insane right
and doing acting in odd ways
yeah i think intelligence this is what i
i have been ineloquent in trying to
describe
it partially because
i try not to think
too deeply through this stuff because
then you become a philosopher i still
aspire to actually building a bunch of
stuff
but my sense is super
intelligence leads to um
deep integration into human society so
like
intelligence is strongly correlated like
uh
intelligence the way we conceive of
intelligence
materializes as a thing
that becomes a fun
entity to have at a party and
with humans so like uh it's a mix of wit
intelligence humor like intelligence
like knowledge ability to do uh
reasoning and so on but also
humor emotional intelligence ability to
love
to uh to dream to share those dreams
to um
to play the game of um human
civilization the push and pull the whole
dance of it the whole dance of life and
i think that kind of super intelligent
being
is not the thing that uh
that worries me i think that ultimately
will enrich life it's again the dumb
algorithms the dumb algorithms that
scale
in the hands of people that are too
don't study history that don't study
human psychology and human nature just
applying too broadly for selfish
near-term interests that's the biggest
danger yeah i think it's not a new
danger right um right i now know
how i should use twitter and how i
shouldn't use twitter right
i like to provoke people into thinking i
don't want to provoke people into
outrage it's not fun it's not a good
thing for humans to do right and i think
that when you get people into outrage
they take sides
and taking sides is really bad but i
think that we're all beginning to see
this and i think that actually
i'm very optimistic about how things
will evolve because
you know
i wonder how much
how much productivity has twitter and
social media has taken out humanity
because how many now um i mean so the
good thing about twitter is it gives
power so it gives voice to minorities
right and and that's good to some degree
but i wonder how much
voice does it give to
all sorts of other
problems that don't need this emergency
by the way when you say minorities i
think
uh
or at least if i were to agree with you
what i would say is minorities broadly
defined in these small groups
of
people that
uh it magnifies
the concerns of the small versus the big
that is good to some degree
um but i think
i mean i have to be careful because i
think i have a a very
i mean i think that the world isn't that
broken right i think the world is pretty
cool place i think academia is really
great i think
climate change presents a really
interesting problem for humanity that we
will solve i like how you said it's a
pretty cool problem
for civilization it's a big one what's
the budget i wanna there's a bunch of
really yeah really big problems that if
solved can
significantly improve the quality of
life or large that ultimately is what
we're trying to do
improve like how awesome life is for the
maximum number of people yeah and i
think the the coming back to
consciousness
i don't think the human universe is
doomed to heat death right it's one of
the optimists that's why i want to kind
of nudge you into thinking that time is
fundamental because the time is
fundamental then suddenly
you don't have to give it back
the univ the universe just constructs
stuff you know and what we see around us
in our construction i know everyone's
worried about how fragile civilization
is and i mean look at the fundamentals
we're the good we're good until the
earth the the sun expands right
we've got quite a lot of resource on
earth we're trying to be quite
cooperative humans are nice to each
other
when they
when they're not under
enormous stress we're coming back to the
consciousness thing are we going to send
human beings to mars or conscious robots
to mars or are we going to send some
hybrid
um and uh i don't know the answer to
that question right now i guess you know
elon's gonna have a pretty good go at
getting there i'm not sure whether
i have my i have my doubts but i'm not
qualified you know i'm sure people have
their doubts that computation works yeah
but but but i've got it working and i
you know and most most of the cool
technologies we have today
and take for granted
like the airplane aforementioned
airplane were things that people doubted
every like majority of people doubted
before they uh came to life yeah and
they come to life and speaking of hybrid
ai and humans
it's fascinating to think about all the
different ways that
hybridization that merger can happen i
mean we have currently have the
smartphone so there's already a hybrid
but there's all kinds of ways that
hybrid happens how we and other
technology play together like a computer
how that changes
the fabric of human civilization is like
wide open who knows who knows if you
remove
if you remove cancer
if you remove major diseases
from humanity
uh
there's going to be a bunch of
consequences we're not anticipating uh
many of them positive
but many of them negative
many of them most of them at least i
hope are weird and wonderful and and fun
in ways that are totally unexpected and
we sitting on a porch with a bottle of
jack daniels and a rocket we'll say
kids these days don't appreciate how
hard we had it back in the day
you